i don't think that we can change the
whole world or the whole picture but i
think that it starts with some small
actions that are growing over time
and i hope i really hope to see them
growing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration
with secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i have the privilege of
speaking to aynard ghez the ceo of
papaya global a truly a remarkable
company from the israeli ecosystem an
entrepreneur with 15 years of experience
she is a leading expert in global
payroll and global workforce management
she co-founded papaya after seeing the
technology gap in the global payroll the
company combines her twin passions
technology and global hr to start a
revolution in global payroll management
papaya's innovative software provides a
total workforce solution allowing
companies to manage all of their global
people payroll and payment operations
through a single dashboard welcome to 20
minute leaders
i've been waiting years to do this
episode together because you are working
on the intersection of i think one of
the most fascinating fields in in our
society in our economy talking about you
know everybody's talking about
globalization everybody's talking about
human resources and hiring but but
technically it's a challenge and as the
world becomes more globalized compliance
is
is remaining with a question mark on how
do you manage this difficult process
as different generations are adapting
differently to the workforce you have
different expectations and you have
different environments in which people
hire and people provide services and so
you're really sitting on this cutting
edge advancements of of enabling the
world to understand and to deal with
this complexity and so i'm excited in
these 20 minutes to sort of pick your
brain on this
structure that you've that you've built
in this thesis you've been building over
these last six years
with one of the most you know amazing
companies that came out of israel and so
i knot thank you very much for being
here
thank you for inviting me
take me back six years
where where are you at in terms of your
own life in terms of your thinking
process
that leads to the creation of popeye
global
so i mean the whole creation of papaya
global is kind of it's boring in in one
sense and it's very unusual if you're
looking on the kind of a
other founder stories because in reality
i've been dealing with global workforce
for 20 years now okay a bit more even
um
and
i started
after my military service with an
holding company doing mega projects in
africa so we did massive relocation at a
time into the continent on different
sectors from different
nations and eventually different kind of
profession
um end of 2008 beginning of 2009
i decided that i want to start my own
venture
er not the best timing to start a
startup and eventually ended up with
a just establishing a
business
called relocation source that is
providing outbound and inbound corporate
relocation services to and from israel
and few years later
i was
seeing the shift of my clients to china
actually
the the first one that asked us to
relocate a few team members to china was
at the time a small company called waze
and they had the need of relocating few
team members to china and i was like
okay what's going on in in china i mean
why i mean all of a sudden it's becoming
an interest to anyone and so i decided
that i need to spend some time there and
this is where i started my second
company called expert source a helping
clients to eventually start
a global
business in china
without having a local legal presence on
ground so we did everything from them on
the employment side and a few years
later i mean i did some expansion into
the continent i really liked asia
and a few years later i i kind of had
the same thinking with myself
okay what i want to do a
when i'm gonna grow old
and
and actually i was browsing through tons
of ideas because i think the main
challenge for me is to understand if the
knowledge that i have
is actually um interesting enough or
have is solid enough to transform it
into a scalable product because i was
very minded of providing services and
how do i solve problems and i'm very
good in in operational problems and how
to solve them and and make things happen
but in reality i was um
i didn't know i mean with myself if this
isn't a big enough or interesting enough
and it can be a product
and
when i was starting kind of my own
research i kind of realized that at the
time
a lot of
hr hrs payroll companies in the us
started to grow very quickly like
xenophage and gusto and in others
and i said okay but what's the
difference i mean if the need is there
in the u.s it's definitely i mean a much
bigger problem globally when you are
kind of
leaving your main country and so on um
so let's make it happen and this is
where we started with
the idea of papaya in a really kind of
the incubation of of this and i mean one
one sentence as you said really caught
my attention because you said yeah it's
the fascinating word and you know i mean
i think that the first thing that i
heard
during the first year is oh this is such
a boring topic
i think that the world compliance really
kind of got a very different perspective
over i mean during the five or six years
that we are in business and
i'm i think it's a good thing eventually
because you know in reality
um we we all paying taxes right it's not
going to change i mean if we like it or
not
and we all need to just to remain
compliant uh so uh yeah so um
i mean
i think you know we will may talk about
entrepreneurship just a little bit but
you know the fact that you're you know
you're mentioning how today it's trivial
that we're that in hindsight you know we
look at it as one of the most
fascinating topics yet six years ago
people didn't really want to talk about
this as it was sort of on the boring
scale effectively today this is what
every news article is about the great
resignation the gig economy the consumer
behavior of the new workforce
so if you're looking back and and i love
the differentiation of how you're seeing
you know these great companies gusto and
zenefits back in the united states and
you're saying well well but but i've
seen the world africa asia israel i've
seen the needs of companies and the
emerging compliance restrictions
something is something needs to happen
here and so
when you started out
how
how did your thesis change over time
were there different milestones
throughout the last six or seven years
that really changed your thesis
regarding what companies need and want
in terms of their global payroll
management
so it's an interesting question because
i think that many things changed i mean
in the beginning we thought that
eventually
i mean the best use case for papaya will
be kind of small to medium businesses
where you don't have infrastructures in
place and currently i think that
as the company is bigger and much more
global this is where i mean the the
scaling and eventually the pain is
becoming much much bigger
obviously i mean
the one thing is payroll is that it's a
huge battle neck and it's a recurring
process right i mean we are just
currently on the end of fema so it means
that everyone that is processing payroll
is kind of breathing i mean
because it just if i finish the cycle
but in less than five days time they're
gonna start all over again and it's kind
of a race against time everyone needs to
be paid everyone needs to pay correctly
you need to collect tons of data and
every single country really kind of
change
things that you are not aware of and so
on and i think that we did not realize
that this is a problem that actually
will meet us on on growth on a fortune
clients i mean we thought okay we are
kind of and because also our thesis was
kind of looking on what gaston's
benefits are solving it was kind of smb
market i mean and so on we were okay
this is
relatively the same so i think this is
the main thing that has changed the
second thing that has changed and this
is also why we did them
quite a large acquisition on the domain
this year
is
understanding that our job actually does
not end
with the data processes of the payroll
uh and paying
like payroll and processing the payments
themselves to the payroll authorities um
this is a huge pain and a
that doesn't have a good solution and i
think majority of the problems in
payroll i mean eventually lends
with the fact that it's a very local
process
so companies are trying to act global
but in reality you need to become local
in every single stage and there is this
huge gap between
compliance and regulation and anti-money
laundry a kind of processes and so on
and and what you need to do in order to
be a local business on i mean in order
to make it and those are the gaps that
we are trying to bridge i also think
that an interesting fact is that we
started papaya co-founded papaya 2016
about 2017 or 2018 war was that the new
gdpr a kind of regulation coming to
place
and then we realized that in reality now
you have another challenge because
payroll data is the most sensitive data
in the organization which does gdpr
regulation yeah i mean payroll companies
in reality i mean they're not
it's a small business i mean you cannot
ask from a small business to comply with
those massive regulation just because
they they handle this sensitive data and
i was just telling to someone yesterday
that
in reality if you're looking about the
payroll evaluation i mean in terms of
countries um
in the past five years the process has
become
massively more complex i mean tons of
other requirements but from the other
hand i mean if i'll tell you okay like
pay five ex on every payslip you'll say
why i mean does not make sense i mean
you know i mean this is kind of so there
is also a huge gap between requirements
and market requirements and and
legislation and so on to the need of the
clients the need of the end user and
this is where we are trying to bridge
and i remember that i mean one of the
questions that we kind of we ask
ourselves i mean where does it going to
land i mean what the technology what
type of technology we need to eventually
bring to the world in order to make it
very feasible and now i think that the
challenges that we see in technology are
much bigger than the one that we saw
five years ago because we understand
that the biggest win is the efficiency
is the zero mistake and the ability to
really trust payroll as it is a full
financial service and not just an hr
service which unfortunately i mean the
the the the world still considered
payroll as an hr service
right
i i love the
the distinction to to create a global
company you have to realize that you're
effectively creating many local
companies
and uh
and i think that that's a that's a
mature it's a level of maturity of a
market that
that you know the the simplicity behind
the idea let's go global you know it has
a lot of implications and and uh and it
sounds like you you had to to really
learn it as we say in hebrew on your
skin and that
that this is that this is the reality
and if you're looking today at you know
you have you have two sides you have the
company side and you have the consumer
side the people that are getting
onboarded
they they've also seen a shift right in
in the last few years how did you
experience that shift and sort of how do
you think through now
as to where we are and and and what what
does what what this new
construct really means
so oh i mean you're now you're taking me
to the part that i like most because i
think oh i i currently understand that
payroll needs to be reinvented uh
because in reality what happened in
kovid is that everybody started kind of
shifting themselves and it was kind of
temporary okay i mean people follow the
sun people follow in non-coveted
countries people follow places where
they could work remotely some countries
created amazing kind of tax benefits and
make it very very easy to digital nomads
just to settle in but in reality those
people in many cases moved but their
payroll stayed behind
so now you have one person that lives
here and his payroll is actually being
paid in another country just because
it's easier for him just because the
company does not want to eventually
change it
and this is kind of um a reality
that i think that governments today
don't understand that they need to to
change so i i think that in in reality
we all need to be digital nomads and our
income needs to be global then i mean if
you have kind of a global account and
then you can split it between between
countries and make it very very easy to
understand okay if i worked 20 days
from this year in spain and 10 days in
france and so on okay just split the
income
um so i think that the whole kind of
rethinking about payable on a global
kind of transformation is something that
the world really really needs to do and
and you know i mean government always
kind of they could take time to adopt
things and to understand trends and to
change things but i think that in the
next two or three years you're gonna see
countries that are the big winners i
mean because they have a very very
um good tax environment uh so you can
settle in there even if you are
traveling from there back to your home
country you are coming as a tourist
eventually um
and this will be a very big driver the
second thing this is more about the
personnel
is the fact that i think that we have a
very big opportunity to create to
transform payroll to be
the biggest benefit in the organization
because the young generation i'm i'm
gonna sound old now uh on on the
uh with my 42 years old in the world but
i mean they don't i think that's their
ability to currently take
a wide financial kind of commitment for
the long run and the c a and so on
decisions is quite limited and in
reality i mean the biggest commitment
that you're gonna take is probably
mortgage to buy a house or or kind of a
specific loan to i mean to something
that happens currently in your life and
what you're doing at this point of time
you are taking the data from the company
you are going by yourself to banks and
you are asking them to to finance you to
give you the best offer they can
aside from being the banks to the
institutes and say okay i mean let's
transform it into a benefit let's assure
that if i know that i have like a great
buying power of my employees i bring the
banks to eventually kind of bring them
the best benefits and the same with
flexible pay i mean who said that it
makes sense for you to be paid every two
weeks every one month i mean in reality
maybe you want to be paid in a more
flexible this is kind of
in some way you are always financing
your company right i mean every single
day that you are working and you're not
getting paid i mean your your company
has the obligation story too so all of
this reality in taking i mean very
flexible data and transforming the
payroll and saying okay
i mean this is your funds we are just
keeping it because you already earned
this and now let's assure that we are
utilizing it or you can utilize it
better we will help you to utilize it
better we will bring you better benefits
we will bring you a better way to
utilize it but you take the ownership
you take the control i am not the one
that dictating that on the first of
every month you're gonna get paid
because this is kind of what's
comfortable for me because maybe this is
not meet with the things that you need
so i think that this is kind of the
transformation
that
needs to happen i mean in in all cases
in terms of kind of creating this uh
something that
meet your lifestyle meet your the place
that you work meet your specific needs
so as you're now
in a very different position than you
were six years ago with hundreds of
employees so many different customers a
brand that is associated with
a leader in in this field
how do you do you have a
a
responsibility here
to act on this vision you're saying that
some things need to happen that lives
will change as a result of of of these
different constructs and different
mechanisms
well you know it kind of makes sense
that papaya global is is one of the only
solutions out there today that has the
potential of actually making the sleep
and bringing us to this new construct is
that something that you're taking with
you or because it's a different mindset
than you know when you're just starting
out a company and you're saying well let
me jump
make the leap and maybe one day i'll
revolutionize something no you're
actually deleting
so i agree yes and i think that yes when
you're starting a company you're in a
survival mode right you need to assure
that i mean
i mean
you can kind of go beyond tomorrow and
the day after the day after now we have
the rare opportunity to kind of design
reality and to take this and kind of uh
start designing the processes so i'm
very active here because i think that um
in reality this can create tons of
transformation
uh in in many many
important things
between countries between nations uh
improve people's life and so on so i'm
involved in some initiative you know i
mean i i don't think that we can change
the whole world or the whole picture but
i think that it starts with some small
actions that are growing over time
uh and i hope i really hope to see them
growing
i love it hey not i really want to thank
you for
for spending this time with me at
10 p.m
in in israel i'd say
i think it is six years just because you
you managed to get to a position where
you're now designing reality and you're
not in survival mode i see that you're
that you're working just as hard and i
and i appreciate all the all the time
and more than that the inspiration that
you're providing to our ecosystem it's a
it's really amazing to see from the side
you know the support that you're
providing to to young entrepreneurs and
to into the ecosystem in general and
it's a and and i personally love the
work that you're doing with papaya
global and i've been
excited to pick your brain for a while
20 minutes is not nearly enough but but
it's definitely enough to get the to get
the curiosity running and thank you for
everything
thank you i really enjoyed it
thank you
[Music]
you